Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
house the dragon video all about the dragon dreams
that characters have had on the show in Dragon
dreams from later in the timeline during the
events of Game of Thrones there have been at least
five different members of the House Targaryen that
we know of so far that have had really important
Dragon dreams in the next several years we'll
probably learn about several more once they do
later parts of the timeline earlier parts of the
timeline with other members of their family if
you're brand new to the channel I'm doing videos
for all the house of the Dragon episodes just like
I did for the main Series be sure to subscribe to
get them but Dragon dreams are basically visions
of the future that are specific to people of
Valyrian descent we mostly just hear about them
from the Targaryen family but that doesn't mean
that they're the only family from ancient valyria
that had them and there are other characters that
we know of who have visions of the future using
other methods like bran is a green Seer before he
became the three-eyed raven green seers can see
through time using the weirwoods also because
of the way bran Stark's Powers work now as the
three-eyed raven I know a lot of you will ask are
Dragon dreams really just Bran Stark using his
powers to try and travel back in time and warn
previous Targaryen Kings and other people in their
family about the coming of the long night that
would be funny like this is all just Bran Stark
secretly trying to warn everyone in the past but I
don't think that's what's happening I don't think
that he tries to mess with the pass After he finds
out about how he messed up Hodor but later in the
timeline because of all the wars the infighting
rebellions in their family cross Westeros things
like Robert's Rebellion most of the ancient
information that the targaryens had about their
Valyrian specific powers granted to members of
their bloodline were lost like eventually Samwell
starts learning about some of these things because
of documents in the Citadel we also learned
that's how rhaegar learned about the prophecy
too so like at some point during the timeline
all this important knowledge is lost along with
a lot of the ancient Valerian Secrets the really
important stuff like how to create new Valyrian
steel Valyrian pyromancers in how the Valyrian
blood Mages created Dragon bonding because there's
still lots of dragon eggs that could potentially
hatch later in the timeline so if you knew how
that magic work you could create a whole new line
line of dragon riders that were not targaryens but
what happened is that much later new dragon
dreamers were probably born to their family
across the timeline without really understanding
their abilities or what the dreams meant like the
same thing happens to all the stark children in
present day during Game of Thrones all the stark
children are born with the ability to worry but
bran is the only one who actually learns how it
works and practices it develops it that's what
they mean when they say the Stark children have
wolf dreams like Jon Snow still has wolf dreams
all the stark children who still have direwolves
that are still alive have wolf dreams it's
basically them warging into their dire roles at
night without understanding what it means because
they're doing that Jon Snow sequel series maybe
we'll see some wolf dreams from Jon Snow on that
but Dragon dreams Dragon dreamers are basically
prophets in the Targaryen family who see visions
of the future they're like human spoilers here's
what's going to happen in the future but none
of them really understand what the dreams mean
exactly most of them misinterpret them in most
of the dreams wind up having tragic payoffs so
I'll do all these Dragon dreams in chronological
order the first one one we know of is from dany's
the dreamer in ancient valyria she's the daughter
of Anar Targaryen about a hundred years before the
birth of aegon the Conqueror while the Targaryen
family was still living in the Valyrian Freehold
dany's one of aenar's children had a vision
of the doom of valyria her father took all
the family's Holdings all their current dragons
which included a young version of valerian the
black dread he sits here on viserys's model I
think these are meant to represent the different
houses of all the dragonlords like the specific
houses that they lived in inside the Freehold
he sailed their entire family to a small trading
Outpost that they had established many years prior
called Dragonstone it was still just a trading
post at that time its construction was meant to
be a copy of the Freehold with the inaugurion here
that's the place where the ancient Valerian blood
Mages created Dragon bonding and practiced their
Arts the valerians which are also of Valyrian
descent established drift Mark which is the island
right next to it long before the targaryens came
to Westeros so technically the valerians came
to Westeros first but they weren't dragonlords
so they were like way less influential way less
powerful within the Freehold in the free hold
valyrians didn't have a king or queen they were
ruled by a democratic Council like a house of
Lords a house of dragon Lords make all the jokes
you want as the title implies only the dragon
Lords had right to sit on the council and make
decisions we don't know what the exact text of
her Dragon dream was like what she actually spoke
but at some point in a flashback in some future
show like an aegon the Conqueror series that HBO
said that they're doing or an ancient Valerian
Freehold series we'll see her in a flashback speak
the dragon dream many volcanoes exploding all at
the same time we should move to our summer home
on Dragonstone and even though Danes is the oldest
Dragon dreamer in their family we know about
she's only the oldest recorded Dragon dreamer so
there are probably other members of their family
previously who had Dragon dreams and they just
didn't record them about a hundred years after
the family had inhabited Dragonstone aegon the
Conqueror was born as the next recorded member
of their family to have dragon dreams there were
probably others that popped up but he's the next
one that we know about the difference is the aegon
the Conqueror kept his Dragon dream secret or he
only told his sisters or just like a couple people
and that's why we're only just learning that he
had them on House of the Dragon because a lot of
the events were recorded by maesters who weren't
actually privy to the actual event so they didn't
have the entire truth and because we've also
learned that Dragon dreamers have many many Dragon
dreams like it's not like a one-time only kind
of thing they just have continual Dragon dreams
and you only hear them speaking about some of them
aegon also probably had other Dragon dreams but we
just learned about the most important one that he
had which is basically about the long night and it
is the prophecy of the prince who was promised
that they talked about on the main show aegon
himself called it A Song of Ice and Fire which
is the title of George RR Martin's novel series
adapted for the main show his dream was basically
that eventually the white walkers in the night
king would cover the world in ice in one of his
descendants would stop it but like they say most
people misinterpreted their dragon dreams and none
of them ever understood when they would actually
be paid off or come to pass so for instance all
the kings after him that knew the prophecy just
assumed that it would happen at any given moment
aegon wound up having the prophecy etched on the
Valyrian dagger that the family had brought
with them from ancient Valeria using Valerian
pyromancer techniques which were eventually lost
the Valerian pyromancers probably morphed into
the pyromancer's guild who created a wildfire
later in the timeline like I said a lot of their
Valyrian knowledge was probably lost over time
everyone later in the timeline we see wielding
the dagger doesn't know about the prophecy brain
could probably use his three-eyed Raven powers
to learn about the prophecy but he's kind of like
the totality of the internet all knowledge on the
internet without a search function he doesn't
really understand the context of everything
he sees it's all just like random information all
bunched together for him after aegon the Conqueror
the next dragon dreamer that we know about at
least right now is viserys the first who's still
alive on the show much to his Chagrin like he
probably thought that he was going to die a long
time before this the only dragon dream specific
to him that he actually had was different from
other Dragon dreams at least that he revealed
on the show was his vision of what he thought
was his future Heir sitting on the Iron Throne
being crowned King in all the dragons roaring as
one but like Daenerys later misinterpreting what
her Visions meant viserys mistakenly thought that
he was seeing his son Balon with Emma who she was
pregnant with at the time on the Iron Throne when
in fact his Dragon dream was probably about aegon
II being crowned the next king in the Roaring of
all the dragons that he was seeing was either
happening during the actual Dance of the Dragons
when the greens and the blacks dragons are all
fighting each other or possibly even more tragic
was him seeing the storming of the Dragon pit when
the commenters in King's Landing eventually sacked
the dragon pit and killed all the dragons that
were trapped inside of the time so his dragon
dream like most of the Dragon dreams were meant
to be tragic ones like it was him seeing that
eventually he'd have another wife because the love
of his life had died and his son was only crowned
because of a mistake leading to the Civil War
that nearly destroyed their entire house so the
big idea here is that Dragon dreams aren't meant
to be good things usually it's something really
really bad that they are foreseeing for instance
the Doom of valyria very very bad after viserys we
we just learned that Helaena Targaryen has Dragon
dreams his daughter with Allison we've never seen
viserys have any scenes with her talking about the
dragon dreams but they kind of implied that they
have very similar personalities like they're both
kind of Geeks she really likes collecting her bugs
viserys really just likes making his models here
playing with his toy model reading about ancient
history so they kind of implied that of all of
his children with Allison she's the one that
he favored most because she's standing like right
next to him at the funeral here and that's usually
reserved for whoever the king liked most we'll
call the viserys and the Helaena scenes deleted
scenes like just scenes of them geeking out over
his model of ancient Valeria talking about the
dragon dreams that both of them have had so far
Helaena has had four different Dragon dreams
that we know about she's spoken about them on two
separate occasions she'll probably have more later
on but during both times she speaks in a string
of consciousness kind of way like a true Prophet
would so it sounds like one dream but she's really
speaking about several different events all just
kind of bunched together the same way that bran
might talk about events that he's seeing with his
three-eyed Raven power the first time she says the
last ring will have no legs that's about aegon the
second's future and like all of her Dreams they're
tragic and paid off in ironic ways another thing
to note too all of Alison's children have scenes
when they're born that foreshadow the methods of
their deaths which they'll pay off in ironic ways
on the show eventually this is the writer's dark
sense of humor a very Game of Thrones thing to
do foreshadowing their deaths during their first
scenes I'll wait to talk more about the dragon
dream for aegon II until they actually pay it
off because it might not happen till future season
her second dragon dream is about Eamonn Targaryen
she says he'll have to close an eye and it was a
reference to Allison saying he'd hundred percent
for sure claim a dragon someday which he did in
vegar soon after this but he gets his eye cut
out her third one hand turns Loom spool of green
spool of black dragons of Flesh weaving dragons
of thread is actually two different dreams but
they're both about the dance of the Dragons itself
hand turns Loom is a reference to Otto Hightower
the hand of the king influencing the dance of the
Dragons the people that fought in the dance of
the Dragon it's like he's directly responsible
for part of it getting started he influences
the king he also influences his daughter Allison
who's leader of the greens he kind of Fosters her
mistrust of rhaenyra the Loom in the dragons of
thread weaving dragons of flesh is a reference to
rhaenyra and Allison's black and green gowns that
they wear which the maesters later used to refer
to the dance of the Dragons as the blacks versus
The Greens in the dragons of Flesh that they
weave are the new children in their family that
they give birth to who become the main fighters
in the dance the dragon writers on both sides
of the conflict they'll be introducing even more
children on the show like even though we're having
a time Jump so we have a bunch of the kids that
we previously saw being older there'll also be
new children coming along in next week's episode
and in future seasons and all of them are born as
Dragon Riders so we'll see 17 different dragons
on the show eventually and what'll probably
happen with Helaena is we'll see her have even
more Dragon dreams as long as she's part of the
show like there's another time Jump in episode
8 older Helaena Targaryen would still be having
new dragon dreams that's kind of like her thing
on the show she's like a living spoiler telling
them about what's eventually going to happen but
at least when she's speaking them on the show none
of the other characters really understand what
she's talking about they just think that it's
all gibberish the next recorded Dragon dreams
in their family are from Daenerys Targaryen on
the main show and those are visions that she
has in the house of the undying it's possible
that she had other dragon dreams and just didn't
speak about them Daenerys is also named for the
original daenys the dreamer thus the connection
with them both having Dragon dreams and also
like daenys like all the other targaryens that
have dragon dreams all of daenerys's dreams are
meant to have tragic ends in the house of the
undying her Visions start with the Iron Throne
Room covered in what she thinks is snow and she
misinterprets this thinking that she'll eventually
retake the red keep in Westeros but all this stuff
falling around her actually winds up being the ash
from her sacking King's Landing then she has a
vision of herself touching the iron throne and
she mistakenly thinks that it's her sitting on the
Iron Throne eventually like oh I'll eventually Win
It I'll become the next ruler of Westeros like my
ancestors before me when in fact tragically it's
actually about her death like she saw a vision of
her death because after this she sees more literal
vision of the long night like aegon did when she
passes beyond the wall that was a reference to the
events of the Season 7 finale with the night
King destroying the wall with viserion and
the one she sees right after this of Khal Drogo
with her baby Rhaego that she had with him was
her seeing her actual death like the vision was
her meeting them again in death will be together
but it'll happen because she's dead and that's
meant to be connected to her visions from the
iron throne room in the Iron Throne itself like I
said though this is only the beginning we'll get
more dragon dreams from Helaena and also when they
cover different periods of the timeline like the
blackfyre rebellion with different characters
aegon's conquest with aegon himself other
characters ancient valyria with other characters
we'll probably see other members of their family
who also had Dragon dreams which will connect the
different shows across the timeline if there's any
other Dragon dreams that you spotted that I didn't
talk about in the video or any questions you have
about the actual Dragon dreams just write them in
the comments in my full episode 8 video will post
Sunday night after they release it everyone click
here for my house the Dragon episode 8 video I'll
be sure to update the link as soon as I post that
and click here for all my other house the dragon
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!